surprise
i bet you thought you'd seen the last of
me
dr addison montgomery is returning to
grace sloane memorial it's really nice
i've missed it grey's anatomy will be
welcoming back kate walsh for the
upcoming 18th season
the news was revealed thursday in a very
special video message by addison herself
surprise
i bet you thought you'd seen the last of
me
e.t can confirm kate will appear in
multiple episodes during the upcoming
season and while it's unclear when or in
what context the actress's first
appearance will be she shared her
excitement on instagram
well well well would you look who it is
that's right my loves dr addison
montgomery is coming back to grace low
memorial hospital and i'm so excited to
be home again joining shonda ellen and
the rest of the incredible cast kate
also hit up the comment section writing
i've been waiting a long time for this
just wait until you see what she has in
store for you
the actress first made her gray's debut
as addison in the final moments of the
season one finale in 2005.
what are you doing here
well you know if you bother to return
any one of my phone calls
hi
i'm addison shepard
shepherd
and you must be the woman who's been
screwing my husband
there's always you know with grey's
anatomy there's always there's always
work and then there's stirring up the
pot as well
kate remained a series regular for
seasons two and three before
transitioning to her spin-off private
practice which ran for six seasons until
2013. forget everything that's happened
or hasn't happened between us what i'm
about to say to you is strictly
professional as a physician
and your business partner
okay your girlfriend sucks the
announcement of kate's return to the
medical drama comes a few weeks after
kate burton's return as meredith's late
mother ellis gray was announced that's a
pretty good favorite thing
since season 17 grace has seen a handful
of familiar faces pop back in including
last year's appearances by former cast
members tr knight kyler lee eric dane
mcdreamy himself patrick dempsey
everything is lost
i hate you you love me
god knows i love you and dr april kepner
played by sarah drew you have never
wanted any of this
and i'm just supposed to roll with it
see what happens back in april e.t
caught up with the actress and she
admitted keeping her big return a secret
was not easy i had to keep it a secret
for a little while um
but i think that i was
i didn't fully believe it was happening
until i like literally
signed the contract which didn't come
until you know a while after the initial
conversations but you never know you
never know if the storyline is going to
change or they're going to change their
mind or it's not so i i didn't really
settle into the to the reality that it
was happening until i knew 100 it was
happening and then by that point i was
about to show up on set and so i was
like i can't wait to see everyone
[Music]
you